Pour ne louper aucune vidéo,
abonnez-vous etactivez la petite cloche !
Bonjour les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Que doit-on dire ?
Sabrer
ou sabler le champagne ?
Les deux,
mon capitaine !
Puisque ces deux expressions
ne signifientpas la même chose.
Allez
je me fais mousser !
L'expression « sabrer le champagne »
a vu le jour surles champs de bataille.
Pour fêter la victoire les hussards
de la garde napoléonienne buvaientdu champagne
qu'ils débouchaient,
non pas à la main,
comme vous et moi
mais en utilisantleur sabre.
Un coup sec en faisant glisser le revers de la lame
du flanc de la bouteille
vers le goulot.
Aidé par la pression qui règne à l'intérieur,
le goulot, le bouchon et le muselet
sont violemment éjectés.
« Sabler le champagne » n'a rien à voir.
L'expression signifie :
le boire d'untrait
par analogie à un geste pratiqué en métallurgie,
l'industrie des métaux.
Le métalen fusion est versé d'une traite
dans un moule en sable.
Aujourd'hui,
on utilise cette expression
pour signifier qu'il va couler à flot
lors d'une fête.
Même si vous le savez avec l'alcool,
il nefaut pas pousser le bouchon trop loin.